on en parlait en début d'émission jeudi
prochain l'hôpital du Vésinet en
partenariat avec l'association Art
convergence ont lancé un projet musical
berceuse sur le nom de la restitution de
ces berceuses se fera jeudi prochain à
l'hôpital du Vésinet pour en parler avec
nous Laurence Dupin la présidente de
l'association Art convergence et Anne de
Truchy la chef du service périnatalité
de l'hôpital du Vésinet alors vous
travaillez depuis décembre 2022 sur ce
projet comment est-ce que ça s'est fait
vous nous expliquer en début d'émission
que c'était fait à partir d'une
rencontre c'est un peu insolite
finalement d'amener l'art d'amener la
musique dans un hôpital
est quelque chose qui est tout à fait
connu et reconnu et qui s'est adapté
progressivement au travail hospitalier
parce que travailler hospitalier est
particulier comme ça un monde à part
mais là tel que nous on l'a conçu
c'est-à-dire que vraiment sont des
artistes qui ne sont en rien des
thérapeutes mais ils viennent avec des
patients explorer quelque chose et là on
avait fait le choix de la musique et des
berceuses puisqu'on parle des bébés que
on parle de nouveau-nés même puisque
c'est les bébés sont hospitalisés chez
nous entre 0 et 3 à 4 mois et que la
berceuse semblait une belle une belle
voilà une belle illustration de de ce
moment de musique et à un moment où ça
permettrait au moment de régresser et de
se laisser aussi régresser
pour essayer de toucher le bébé qui
existe encore en elle et qui a été en
contact avec une maman qui
aurait pu être défaillante ou qui est
loin ou qui est moins présente ou quand
la patiente a une maladie ce qui est
généralement le cas chez nous peut être
éloigné en distance ou voilà de donc
c'était c'était ça qu'on avait envie de
faire en fait voilà donc on a pu faire
appel à Charlie dehors de Surville qui a
un musicien que connaissait Laurence et
en fait on a proposé aux mamans je sais
pas si je continue mais de d'être autour
d'un dispositif c'est que chaque maman
disposait d'un instrument électronique
qu'on appelle un pas des dingues
directionnels elles étaient six autour
d'une table
Charlie doigt leur donnait l'accès à un
instrument qu'elle choisissait et on a
eu un pianiste enfin il travaillait en
conjointement avec Vincent précieuseux
travailler confort les doigts et lui
initiait une première mélodie sur la
base du prénom du bébé choisi pour le
jour J c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait à peu
près une à deux berceuses créées par
Atelier deux heures deux heures et demie
et ensuite les mamans reprenaient enfin
la maman désign du jour choisissait en
disant non ça ça me convient pas et en
fait après Vincent adaptais en do mineur
enfin c'était vraiment très amusant et
c'était en direct et après la maman
reprenait les notes sur le pad et elle
donnait le là et les autres mamans après
choisissez un autre instrument et
embryait et finalement on arrivait à
avoir une composition commune
vraiment à une co-création c'est ça qui
était particulièrement intéressant et
elle s'en emparer on a même les bébés
qui jouaient un peu moi on enregistrait
pas tout mais c'était vraiment assez
étonnant comme comme c'était vraiment
une co-création je crois que c'était ils
sont les lettres du prénom du bébé cette
CC correspondait à une note de musique
du coup pour créer cette perceuse sur le
prénom de l'enfant le langage musical
anglo-saxon s'écrit et sous forme de
lettre en fait et chaque lettre
correspondant à une note de en langage
latin et donc c'est comme ça qu'on a on
a fait ce choix pour initier les
mélodies et bien je vous propose
d'écouter un extrait tout de suite c'est
la berceuse sur le nom de Adjara
[Musique]
le même sur le même rythme c'était
vraiment très du moment très joli à voir
et alors sur le plan médical quel bilan
vous en faites du coup de ce projet
musical alors c'est c'est un peu
compliqué parce que sur le plan médical
pour pouvoir faire
donner des résultats en médecine il faut
avoir une grande cohérente etc donc ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que clairement
c'était un moment de calme de
tranquillité de solidarité aussi entre
les mamans elles se sont beaucoup
entraînées d'entraide et
on avait des moments qui étaient calmes
le soir des qui sont normés facilement
des bébés aussi et ça c'est pas un
résultat qu'on a aussi souvent que ça on
a un autre atelier berceuse qui est
animé par une psychologue dans le
service mais où c'est des perceuses
toutes écrites qui sont proposées et
c'est aussi des moments qui peuvent
faire entrer dans dans ce on va dire
cette difficulté de l'endormissement
qu'on la plupart des bébés donc c'est
quelque chose qu'on qu'on a à cœur de
travailler dans le service Web José
Cachin vous qui êtes mère adjoint à la
Culture de la Ville de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux vous en pensez
quoi de cette initiative je suis
subjuguée et
je suis admiratif
de tels je trouve ça absolument
remarquable bon là on est typiquement
dans l'expression qui consiste à dire
que la musique adoucit les mœurs mais
non je trouve ça exceptionnel je suis un
fervent admirateur de ce type de projet
là c'est ce qu'on se disait un peu tout
à l'heure en aparté ce sont aussi des
projets de ce type là qu'on essaie de
développer nous au niveau de la culture
à Montigny je sais que dans enfin dans
le cadre de la saison prochaine on a été
sollicité par un ITEP
de telle sorte à pouvoir encadrer
un groupe de six enfants âgés de 6 à 14
ans qui présente des troubles du
comportement avec la présence d'une
éducatrice d'une thérapeute mais aussi
d'une professeure de notre conservatoire
des arts afin de mener un projet
plastique voilà un peu dans le même
esprit que ce que vous pouvez faire donc
moi je suis ravi d'être sur ce plateau
avec avec ces deux personnes invitées
devant moi parce que je me retrouve je
me redonne mais bon choix moi je me
retrouve complètement dans ce type de
projet là et je pense que alors c'est
une exposition qui est prévue c'est ça
il y a une exposition parce qu'il y a
des photos qui ont été prises et surtout
il y a une vidéo qui a été faite pendant
plusieurs
périodes et donc ils vont être exposés
dans l'hôpital et la musique va émaner
va sourdre de plusieurs monolithes alors
donc c'est des des instruments en bois
qui ont été sculptés pour une autre
exposition et qui sont absolument
superbes et qui vont être exposés aussi
dans le hall de l'hôpital et vous allez
faire aussi la restitution de toutes ces
berceuses donc jeudi à partir de 16h30
il va y avoir plusieurs personnalités
qui qui vont venir tout à fait
en version concert ce qui est pas
forcément la version enregistrée que les
mamans vont avoir il y aura donc Vincent
précieuseux que vous avez aperçu sur la
vidéo qui sera accompagné par Julie
sevillafresh qui est une violoncelliste
connue et qui vont jouer donc ces
berceuses en annonçant des 21 prénoms
dans l'ordre alphabétique pour et que
les mamans vont entendre jouer en fait
pour la seule fois de cette manière là
ensuite elles pourront retrouver sur une
playlist
leur berceuse en fait elles ont chacune
leurs pochettes de disques avec leur
berceuse enregistrées et elles auront
une boîte à musique sur enfin sorte de
boîte à musique sur lequel elles
pourront poser leur téléphone
voilà ce que je voulais rajouter
effectivement
on a aussi contacté un lycée
professionnel du Chesnay et on a demandé
à la classe de d'aménagement des espaces
qui fait aussi la menuiserie de nous
fabriquer un petit objet en bois sur
lequel on pourrait poser le portable et
chaque élève a fabriqué un objet en bois
pour un enfant un bébé et il va venir
donner aux mamans donc on a trouvé que
ça a donné encore une autre dimension et
du sens aussi pour et pour nos mamans et
pour nos bébés et pour ses élèves voilà
ça c'était fait grâce à Vincent Blandin
qui est le proviseur de ce collège et
bien merci beaucoup Anne de Truchy et
Laurence dupy d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en plateau alors pour rappel
du coup toutes les berceuses seront
retransmises lors d'une exposition
ouverte au public tous les jours de 14h
à 18h à l'hôpital du Vésinet et ce sera
alors comme et ce sera du coup du 15
juin jusqu'au 18 septembre comme on le
disait tout à l'heure